hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime operor and today i will be talking
about the single
biggest unsolved mystery in the demon
slayer story
this is a secret that is directly
related to the birth of the demons
including muzon himself and if there is
a demon slayer sequel
sometime in the future this secret will
definitely be a critically important
part
of the new story in fact this
unsolved mystery was directly referenced
in the final
chapter of the demon slayer manga which
was not a coincidence
in my opinion so let's get into it if
you enjoyed the demon slayer content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going please leave a like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps
a lot and i'm not just saying that it's
how the youtube algorithm works
if you like and comment you are
supporting this video
and of course if you are new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you are looking for
more demon slayer content
don't forget to check out our large and
growing demon
slayer playlist i will link the playlist
down
in the description and in the pinned
comment
finally this video will contain demon
slayer manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned okay so throughout the course of
the demon slayer story
there were a lot of important secrets
and mysteries
but most of them have been resolved the
mystery of the dance of the fire god and
its connection to the breath of the sun
the connection between yorichi and
kokushibo the question of whether a
demon could ever
overcome the sun the question of whether
a human who became a demon could ever go
back to being human
all of these important mysteries have
been resolved by the time that the
original manga
came to an end but the one big mystery
that has never been fully resolved
is the mystery of the blue spider lily
and the creation
of the demon race the blue spider lily
is the reason why muzon became a demon
in the first place
and as such it is the key ingredient to
creating the entire
demon race the blue spider lily also
appears
in the very last chapter of the demon
slayer manga
so if there is any form of sequel to the
story which is highly likely in my
opinion because demon slayer has been
insanely profitable the blue spider lily
will play an important role in that
sequel so what do we really know about
this mysterious and extremely important
plant
muzon the first known demon and the
daddy of all the other demons
was born over 1 000 years ago as a very
sickly child
he was diagnosed with a terminal disease
that was expected to kill him before he
reached the age of 20.
since muzon was part of a wealthy family
they brought in doctors from across
japan
in an attempt to treat muzon's illness
one doctor in particular gave muzon a
highly experimental
and untested medicine whose main
ingredient was the mythical flower
known as the blue spider lily initially
the medicine didn't seem to have
any effect and this enraged muzon
he became so angry that he ended up
killing the doctor who gave him the
medicine
however after he had already killed the
doctor
muzan realized that the medicine was
having an effect it had just been
delayed
the medicine gave muzon an incredibly
strong body
and it made him virtually immortal he no
longer had to worry about dying before
reaching the age of 20
in fact he would live for over a
thousand years
but because this medicine was so
experimental and because it wasn't
finished
there were serious side effects first
muzon would have to kill and eat other
humans to survive
second muzon could never go out in the
sun
now that the medicine had turned muzon
into a demon
direct contact with the sun would kill
him
muzon wasn't exactly a compassionate guy
to begin with
after all he literally killed the doctor
who was trying to save his life because
he got mad
so for musan the idea of devouring
humans to survive
wasn't a major issue but the idea of
having to hide from the sun for all of
eternity
was a big problem and muzon spent the
rest of his life
trying to figure out a way to conquer
the sun and become
the perfect being muzon came to regret
killing the doctor who gave him the
medicine
because if the doctor had lived he may
have been able to improve the medicine
and make it possible for muzan to go out
in the sun
but since the doctor was already dead he
would never be able to complete
this experimental medicine and this
meant that muzon would have to find a
way to conquer the sun
on his own muzon firmly believed that
finding this mythical blue spider lily
would be crucial for his plan to conquer
the sun
which would in turn allow him to become
the perfect being
and so he spent centuries searching
throughout japan
for this special flower unfortunately
for him
he was never able to find it he
subsequently created many other demons
in the hopes that one of them would be
able to help him find a way to conquer
the sun
and he eventually switched the focus of
his search from the blue spider lily to
nezuko kamado
because nezuko had somehow succeeded in
conquering the sun
despite being a demon so at this point
we might be thinking that the blue
spider lily
is extinct or that it is no longer
relevant to the story
but then in chapter 205 of the demon
slayer manga
the final chapter of the entire series
aopa hashibira the modern day descendant
of inosuke hashibira
discovers several samples of the blue
spider lily
alba is the great grandson ominosuke and
a famous botanist who figured out that
the blue spider lily
only blooms during the day for two or
three days of the year
this incredibly specific and short
blooming period
is likely part of the reason why the
blue spider lily is so hard
to find however due to some unspecified
mistake by alba
all the blue spider lilies that he had
discovered withered away
this implies that these particular
flowers are no longer a threat
in terms of turning someone into a demon
but
the fact that these blue spider lilies
were discovered in the first place
means that the demon threat may not be
over after all if alba could discover
multiple blue spider lilies in modern
times
then clearly these mythical flowers are
still around
they didn't just go extinct a thousand
years ago or something like that
and if they are still around then there
is always the possibility that someone
else will use them to become a demon
either by accident or because they
somehow learned
the truth about the blue spider lily's
mysterious properties
now if the mangakao demon slayer wanted
us to think that the demons were already
gone forever
she probably wouldn't have included the
blue spider lily
in the final chapter after all since
muzon spent
over a thousand years looking for this
mythical plant and could never find it
it would have been very easy for us to
believe that the flower just went
extinct at some point and so it could
never be used to create a demon again
but the mangaka specifically chose to
include
the blue spider lily in the final
chapter and to make it known to us that
it still exists
out there somewhere even in the modern
world
this opens the door for a possible new
demon threat
emerging sometime in the future it is a
remote possibility to be sure
but it's still a possibility as long as
the blue spider lily
is still out there somewhere more demons
could appear
and that means that new demon slayer
content could also appear
and who knows maybe new demons did
appear in the past
already but they've just remained hidden
or maybe they are located in
other countries i've always wondered
what was going on
outside of japan in the demon slayer
world
muzon was obviously japanese but it's
certainly possible that over the past
thousand years some of the demons from
japan moved to other countries
and in fact it's possible that someone
outside of japan
also found out about the blue spider
lily so there could be other muzons
out there in the world the blue spider
lily is a mythical flower
but it is based on the real flower known
as the red
spider lily in japanese folklore the red
spider lily is associated with death and
reincarnation
so it's interesting that the blue spider
lily is associated with the opposite
immortality and eternal life but
at a cost now in the real world the red
spider lily can be found
in other countries not just in japan
so it's possible that the same is true
about the blue spider lily
in the world of demon slayer the blue
spider lily is obviously much more rare
than its red counterpart
but when we're talking about a time span
of thousands of years
there is certainly a possibility that
someone somewhere else in the world
also found this flower and used it for a
purpose
similar to musons at the end of the day
this series is called
demon slayer so if there are no demons
to slay
there is no story since muzon is now
dead
if there is a sequel or any form of
continuation to
this series and judging by how insanely
profitable the series has been
a continuation is very likely in my
opinion then we can be certain that the
blue spider lily
is going to play an important role in
the new story
and personally i can't wait to find out
more
about this incredibly mysterious and
interesting flower
let me know what you guys think what is
the secret of the blue spider lily
and how is it able to transform humans
into demons
do you think that there are other blue
spider lilies out there somewhere
maybe even in other countries finally if
there is a continuation to the demon
slayer story
who do you think will be the villain
will it be some kind of prequel with
muzon as the villain once again will it
be a sequel that features
some other demons who were turned by
muzon at some point in the past
or will it be an entirely different
demon maybe even someone from another
country
who became a demon independently of
muzon by using the blue spider lily
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments
below if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more demon slayer content
right here on the channel don't forget
to leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you still
haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you want to make
sure that you won't miss our videos in
the future
you have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying but that is the
only way to stay up to date on our
videos
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect pate heffa
liam thompson
algertal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life chanel baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh
steelers on hell crews anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica
rathune de ora alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted no ted
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you